running a business is the same as
getting healthy it's a lifestyle
leadership is a lifestyle an infinite
mindset is a lifestyle right so for
example you can't get healthy by going
to the gym for nine hours it doesn't
work right but if you go every single
day for 20 minutes you'll absolutely get
into shape 100% but I don't know when
and it's different times or different
people I mean and leading is the same
thing you can absolutely have fitness
goals you can absolutely have finite
goals within the infinite context of
being healthy but there's a practice
that you have to do you have to get
enough sleep you have to go to the gym
you have to eat well you have to protect
your relationships you know because
healthy relationships really matter to
our health and you have to do all those
things vigilantly and if you miss your
health goal it's okay you keep working
at it and you know you will hit it
business is the same who says that you
have to meet this goal on this arbitrary
date now it helps to drive and it's good
to have incentives and we we're very
goal-oriented species that's fine but if
we miss the thing it's fine we just keep
working towards it like their guidance
they're not absolutes because they're
arbitrary dates and arbitrary numbers
and even if you do hit your fitness goal
you don't get to stop working out you
just you have to keep going for the rest
of your life right and this is what
leading with an infinite mindset means
here's an example this is a normal
scenario in business right we will give
a team a target a goal to hit by a
certain timeframe usually a year because
that's usually when we pay taxes right
that's the only reason things are done
in years right if we pay taxes every 18
months all the goals will be 18 months
right so we usually give people a
financial target and there's two teams
one that is driven solely by hitting
that goal because all they care about is
getting their bonus at the end of that
goal morale is up and down if they
happen to have a good month Morales up
if they have a bad month Morales down
retention is terrible they can't hold on
to employees nobody really trusts each
other the bosses toxic and right before
the end of the financial year they have
some mad push where they're dropping
prices all over the place and their
managed to drive revenues and hit the
goal right the problem is we bonus that
team we bonus that leader but
of what because of the goal they hit
right and basically what we're doing is
spreading a message to the rest of the
company saying we don't care how you get
there we don't care if you step on your
people we don't care if you act
unethically if you hit your number
you're gonna do very well in this
company versus another team that's doing
extremely well this good steady slow
growth like really really on target you
know it's not the highs and lows the
peaks and valleys morale is super high
retention is amazing to model team they
trust each other they share information
and they miss their goal on the
agreed-upon date right at the end of the
year they're just shy of it but clearly
you can see from the trend data they're
gonna hit it at 13 or 14 months the
problem is we don't give that person
anything we don't give that team
anything right and this is part of the
problem when you have an infinite
mindset absolutely have the goals but
the trend matters more how you get there
matters as much if not more and we pay
attention to that so even if I hit my
fitness goal I'm eating better I'm
sleeping better my relationships are
great I'm going to the gym yes I miss my
goal but I know if I just keep going
I'll hit it I'm getting healthier and
healthier right I just got the timing
wrong and this is what we need to build
into business that infinite mindset yes
have the goals yes have the ambitions
yes have the annual targets if we miss
them as long as we're doing the right
things we have the right lifestyle to
take us there that's a much healthier
way to live a life and a much healthier
way to build an organization
[Music]